build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
Bill stranger visions is a project by
Heather Dewey hag board where she uses
DNA to create portrait sculptures of
people who she's never met to create
them she collects DNA from cigarette
butts hair gum and other samples and
then uses software to translate the DNA
into computer models and then makes 3d
printed sculptures here she is with her
own DNA 3d printed sculpture Italian
designer Umberto de Tola made this giant
furniture collection called on V used
old chairs armchairs dressers and beds
and added extremely long legs to them so
they overlook everything turning antique
furniture into surreal pieces of art
Etsy artist Ellen Jewett makes animal
sculptures that combine both realism and
fantasy she went to school for
biological anthropology and fine art and
combined her passions into these works
of art check out our Etsy page to see
them all art teacher Michael Cole paints
custom shoes after just trying it out
for fun he received a lot of interest
from others and now he gives his
customers the ability to pick and choose
exactly how their shoes look all you
have to do is send your shoes to him
with request of colors and theme and
help paint them for you and have them
back to you within a couple of weeks
Cole was actually brought to me by one
of his students that thought he deserved
to be in bdp and I agreed check out his
website for more drawing Kazuki Yamamoto
and Koji Matsuno of Osaka are both
artists that used lattes as their canvas
from 3d latte art like this cat
priceless pieces of artwork like this
replica of the screen they're able to
create momentary masterpieces in 3 to 5
minutes that are then consumed
other examples include this monkey the
Peanuts characters and einstein nina
levy a mother of two and Brooklyn based
illustrator creates one-of-a-kind art on
napkins for her son's daily lunch over
the last six years she's been using
colored markers to create pop culture
based artwork and to date has made over
2000 of them she has a daily napkin blog
where you can check them all out and now
for some pieces from a saga in the stars
a tribute
galaxy far far away a Star Wars blew our
trip other people's clothes is a
self-portrait photo series in which
artist caleb cole selects a certain
outfit and creates a scene around it
he's interested in what the daily lives
of other people are like and tries to
place himself in their lives by stepping
into their shoes so to speak he's been
working on the project for about five
years and each portrait starts with a
particular article of clothing and he
builds the scene around flight
everything is coming up millhouse is a
simpsons tribute song to Milhouse Van
Houten by alle Gertz aka Cosby sweater
also check out our YouTube channel for
other great original songs
espresso machine manufacturer san remo
UK created this music video with the
help of the media workshop that
premiered at the UK Barista
Championships
Sonia Bella Sava plays the Batman theme
as Catwoman in the cosplay piano Episode
two
using loops and a violin Kishi Bashi
performs a few beautiful songs live in
Golden Gate Park
a track and Tommy trash created this
amazing Rube Goldberg music video for
their song tuna-melt directed by Ryan
stack
submit your video as a personal message
here on YouTube or share them with
everyone over at facebook.com/vsaucetwo
wo
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi an entire video dedicated to
your creations and as always wait Kevin
I made you some Vsauce cupcakes I made
it one for each of the channels those
are amazing can I eat the Vsauce two one
yeah I'll just grab this one alright
here we go and as always thanks for
watching